i thought i would do another example of
the partial quotient method for long
division and show that it actually has
some uh positives to it is actually kind
of fun to do so let's say i want to do
something really hairy like 291
divided into
divided into let me just throw some
digits over here
390 actually let's throw another digit
right over here so this is how many
times does 291 go into what is this 9873
9552 and to just kind of get our
bearings we know what 291 times 1 is
that's pretty easy 291 times 1 is
clearly just 291. we know what 291 times
10 is that's clearly 2 900 2910
and let's get something some stuff in
between here that'll help us as we try
to approximate how many times 291 it
goes into this this crazy thing over
here so let's just pick and in the last
example i picked two and five you could
just pick three and six if you want you
could pick two and seven you could pick
whatever you want you could even just do
one one of them one of the above but
let's just say 291
291 times let's try three out 291 times
three so i could do this in my head or i
could just to make sure i don't make a
mistake let me do it right over here so
291 times 3 is
1 times 3 is 3
9 times 3 is 27 2 times 3 is 6 6 plus
two is
eight so this is equal to
eight hundred and seventy three it's
actually strange that that 873 showed up
over there maybe my brain is doing
strange things in the background but
anyway that actually has no relevance to
the actual solution of this problem and
let's also try 291 let's also try 291
times 6
291 times 6. let's figure what that
figure out what that is so 291 times 6
it's actually just going to be this
thing times 2 but i'll just calculated
it
291 times 6 1 times 6 is 6 9 times 6 is
2 times 6 is 12 plus 5 is 17. so it's
1746.
700 746 and you might say sal why did
you go through the trouble of figuring
out this and this and i'm just using
these as some approximation tools when
we try to figure out how many times 291
goes into this whole crazy mess so first
of all let's just look at this whole
thing this is nine million eight hundred
seventy three thousand so let's just say
how many times does 291 go into nine
million
nine million
so 291 times three would be 873
we want to add up we want to have a
bunch of zeros after the 873. so think
of it this way and i'm picking 873
because its leading digit is as close to
the 9 as possible but it's definitely
lower than the 9. so you say okay 873
and i'm gonna have one two three four
zeros behind it so 291 times three will
give me 873 but i have to multiply times
three with one two three four zeros one
two three four zeros to get this number
eight point seven three eight point
seven three million so i have to
multiply by thirty thousand but i got
that straight from this idea that 291
times three is eight hundred and seventy
three so let's subtract this right over
here
let's subtract this two minus zero is
two five
nine three seven minus three is four
eight minus seven is one nine minus
eight is one so now we're left with one
million one hundred forty three thousand
nine hundred and fifty two so which of
these is which of these just gets us
right under that so let's see if we we
don't we can't go to something let's see
if we wanna go to
we can't go straight to 1746 that will
be too big over here we might want to do
873 again but this time we're going to
do 873 thousand
thousand that is equal to 3 and then you
have one two three zero so one two three
three times two hundred ninety one is
eight hundred seventy three three
thousand is eight hundred seventy three
thousand let me write this a little bit
neater my handwriting is
so this is going to be this is going to
be
this is going to be three thousand
three thousand times two hundred ninety
one just let me make sure this is a two
right over here two minus zero is two
and then you subtract again
subtract again
two minus zero is two five minus zero is
five nine minus zero is nine three minus
three is zero
and then you have four minus seven so
the way i like to do it when i have to
start regrouping and borrowing is making
sure i go from the left so i could this
one i could borrow from there so that
this becomes an 11 and then the 4 i can
borrow 1 from here so that becomes a 10
and then this becomes a 14. so 14 minus
7 is seven ten minus eight is two
so i'm down to two hundred seventy
thousand nine hundred fifty two so
what's the the what's right below that
so it seems like we can get pretty close
if we do 291 times six so if you do a
46 and then add two zeros to it this is
going to be times six with two zeros so
this is times six hundred once again
you subtract and let's see i'm only
using the sixes and the threes because i
figured out those ahead of time so i
didn't have to do any extra math so two
minus zero is two five minus zero is
five nine minus six is three
zero minus four well i can there's a
couple of ways you could think about
doing this you could borrow from here
that'll become a six this becomes a ten
ten minus four is six now this one's
lower so it has to borrow as well make
this into a sixteen
sixteen minus seven and i have multiple
videos on how to borrow if i'm doing
that part too fast but the idea is here
to show you a different way of long
division so 16 minus seven is nine so
now we're at 96 352
and once again it looks like the 873 is
about as close as we can get so let me
put an 8
7 3 over here with two zeros so that
will literally be 291 times three with
two zeros times 300 and so once again we
want to subtract here two minus zero you
get a two a five a zero make this a
sixteen make this an eight sixteen minus
seven is nine and then we have to get
close to nine thousand fifty two once
again that eight 873 those digits look
pretty good
eight seven three we still want to
multiply we have to multiply three and
then ten so this is going to be times
thirty right over here
we subtract again two minus zero is 2 5
minus 3 is 2 and then you have 90 minus
87 is 3. i'm doing the subtraction a
little faster so that we can get the
general idea
then we have to go into 322 and how can
we get close to that well actually 291
is pretty darn close to that so it's 200
you go into it one time
one times 291 is 291. 2 minus 1 is 1. 32
minus 29 is 3. so you have a remainder
of 31. 291 cannot go into 31 anymore so
that's our remainder but how many times
did it actually go into this big beastly
number this 9 873 952 well there we just
have to add up all of these right over
here 30 plus three thousand we can even
do it in our head thirty plus three
thousand is thirty three thousand thirty
three thousand six hundred thirty three
thousand nine hundred thirty three
thousand nine hundred and thirty one
thirty three thousand nine 931
and we are done assuming i haven't made
some some silly mistake 291 goes into
this thing 33 931 times with a remainder
of 31.